this way guys hey hey we don't do that  anymore tables are for how did John  how's your culture change going I'll  tell you what man things are finally  calming down around then bolts a boy's  terrorizing greater heights man O'Dell  help  don't you dare room ijz photo shoes and  the only way to stop bad brothers with  good brothers 9uj want residents to what  charity can I write the check  thanks for coming to talk sense into him  according to wins no problem guys  defenders to be nice and marketable we  scare you run teacher oh my I also live  on the ants JJ they cannot be contained  hide your cue bees who is it few other  Josh Island  if you liked this video subscribe below  for more or we're not Jason and Jason  McCord II know you're Devon I'm pretty  sure you're Devon which one of us is  Devon you me I'll be Devon thanks Jason